hello everyone and welcome to another
extremely requested game from
yesterday's charity cup it is from the
final game of day two from round eight
and it's uh dingler and versus
pragananda and uh only uh a month like
after april uh defeated magnus carlsen
in that famous game in the air things
masters if you haven't seen it do check
it out the link will be the first thing
in the description below uh we have here
prague meeting uh against uh well a
member of the candidates tournament uh
now you might be saying but ding is not
playing in the candidates tournament
surely this is a mistake well not really
as of today uh some of you might not
have heard sergey karyakin has been
banned from chess for a period of six
months uh and as this overlaps with the
candidates tournament he will be
replaced by for the moment being learned
as he is the highest rated player uh who
is eligible to qualify for the
candidates but only if he plays 26
classical games before the actual start
of the candidates tournament as that is
uh the required amount uh for him to be
able to play so we'll see this shouldn't
be a problem for him the only problem
would be if he actually plays those 26
games and then he loses rating and he
can no longer qualify via rating but i
don't think that's uh that should be a
problem for ding so here basically
prague was playing against the uh well a
very very probable member of the of the
uh 2022 candidates tournament so it's a
very exciting game very fighting game
you guys will enjoy it uh let's dive
straight into it adding with the white
pieces opens with knight to f3 he goes
for the retti opening uh defined by
prague g3 and c5 uh prague is playing
very principled as the ding is uh
going for
this sort of a hyper modern approach uh
ding uh prague is grabbing the the
center here so bishop to g2 knight to c6
and now striking in the center with d4
we have knight to f6 continuing
development castles and e6 now we have
c4 uh
attacking progress central pawn
structure and now d captures on c4 and
usually as this is a very uh well-known
position queen to a4 is played you
prevent b5 you threaten queen captures
on c4 and the game just continues but
here uh ding goes d captures on c5 so
it's uh not as common as the line that
we've discussed but also
very much
a playable one so here uh prague trades
queens captures captures and the bishop
captures on c5 and of course knight b to
d2 just going after the uh pawn on c4
and if you defend with b5 er hoping that
you would keep your extra pawn then 95
and that's just it black would have to
give up the knight for the rook and the
white will be better for the rest of the
game so prague of course knows that
that's impossible he is familiar with
the line he plays c3 now ruins white's
pawn structure b captures on c3 and it's
a good example if you have to give back
the pawn at least to get something in
return for for just giving back the pawn
uh here we have castles and now knight
to b3 attacking the bishop bishop back
to e7 and now knight f to d4 again
putting pressure on that c6 square uh
and here bishop to d7 can be played if
you don't want to rush anything because
what the ding wants is for prague to
capture on d4 and then ding will fix his
pawn structure with c captures on d4 but
uh prague again shows that he knows this
very well uh he allows this knight
captures with c captures on d4
and now knight to d5 uh an excellent
square for the knight unless the knight
can be uh well just uh uh dislocated
with with a move like e4 but here it
would be a bit premature if he for here
knight to c3 attacks the rook and once
the rook moves somewhere because we are
kind of threatening 92 check to win the
bishop pair uh well let's say rook to e1
you can play bishop to d7 now bishop to
b5 can come again you will be
threatening knight st to check so
already you maybe give black a little
bit uh well a bit too much so here
bishop to d2 adding just guards the c3
square now he's ready to push e4 and now
prague does not allow this he plays f5
guards the e4 square so now knight to a5
for the moment putting the knight on the
edge of the board uh preventing uh
prague from developing the light square
bishop so how do you how do you play
this well just b6 that's the way to do
it we challenge the knight we give the
knight this a very active c6 square now
the bishop on e7 is attacked and the
bishop to f6 now here we have a4
preparing a5 at some point to open up
the a file and just bishop to b7 we
attacked the knight on c6 and now the
position has been reached before it was
reached in 2015 in a game between
harikadrona valley and chavanjing
that ended in a draw after that knight
to e5 was played but here we have bishop
captures and d5 ding deviates from that
game and it is now as of move 18 that we
have a completely new game so the of
course the piece has to be recaptured
with e captures on d5 and now uh knight
back to e5 by ding uh we have bishop the
a6 now you could uh maybe try to prevent
ideas like knight to d7 but this doesn't
really worry prague he just goes for
bishop to a6 the e2 pawn is hanging and
also if you play something like e3 then
we happily trade here we mess up white
spawn structure and then we we we just
continue it's hard to save this could be
anything as the bishops are of opposite
color so if the rooks come off the board
uh shouldn't be uh much but uh ding says
that he can do better of course he plays
king to f1
and now we have rook f2ea threatening to
win a pawn here so f4 and now rook e
back to c8 no longer is the rook needed
here
we have king the e1 unpinning so now we
can move the pawn if we want to and now
bishop to c4 and this is a very good
move by prague
the thing is if you play something like
rook to c2 or let's say you want to play
a very active move with the rook the
problem is white has this a5 move and
now ding is threatening to pick up the
b6 pawn and the bishop will is is not
placed very well here so we would have
to go for something like rook to b2 a
captures rook captures and now maybe not
a a position that you would enjoy okay
prague does have the past a pawn uh but
we will very easily stop it we still
have a bishop here our rooks can easily
be doubled on the a file
so he doesn't like this he plays bishop
to c4 now saying okay if you ever
capture on c4 i can just capture with
the pawn and i get a beautiful past c
pawn so rook d the b1 by ding and now
rook a to b8 here probably wants to play
a6 and b5 and create a pass pawn as he
does have a two to one advantage on the
queen side and rook to b2 now uh with
the idea of doubling up on the b file we
have a6 and now bishop the b4 preparing
bishop to d6 to kick away the rook from
uh from the b8 square
b5 uh trying to create a pass pawn and
the b bishop to d6 now and here prague
has to decide does he move the rook
right away or does he want to trade
bishop for knight first because this is
possible white will first have to react
to this because then if captures
captures you can just capture with the
bishop
so uh it's definitely a possibility if
you think that white's knight here is
stronger than your your bishop on f6 but
still you have the bishop's pair if they
come alive it's definitely worth the
wait so here rook to a8 uh getting the
rook out of harm's way and now ding
decides to go for a5 he blocks the
position
but also in doing so he gives prague
with the past b pawn but it's very
unlikely that this pawn is uh ever ever
going anywhere so here rook to d8
challenging the bishop here bishop to c5
and now rook ate the c8 putting the rook
on the only only open file on the board
but again it's very unlikely that you
are you are breaking through here so
king d2 ding wants to bring his king all
the way to b4 it is the most active
square his king can reach and now g5
pushing on the king's side we have king
to c3 uh prague plays h5 with e3 and now
king to g7 so both players just putting
their uh every piece on optimal square
because before going for that final
breakthrough king to b4 and now rook to
h8 if the h file opens up of course you
want to have a rook on the h file h3
biting and now g4 and now this is the
final a piece of the home of the puzzle
uh if
something like h4 is played and then the
position is completely blocked there is
no way to break through and here we just
call it a day and uh it's it's a draw uh
but ding says i'm not ready to call it a
draw just yet rook to h2 he wants to
continue fighting and okay now prague
plays bishop captures on e5 f captures
on e5 so he gives ding the pass pawn but
also uh he messes up
ding's pawn structure here
bishop back to d3 and now pawn to e6 as
the e6 square is not covered by anything
we can play pawn to e6 pawn to e7 and
this rook will remain a rather pawn will
remain on e7 forever so it will be an
extremely strong pass pawn bishop to e4
and now pawn to e7 and now uh the thing
is uh here you could continue in a in a
lot of different ways uh but prague
plays king to f7 he has a very specific
idea in mind uh even though the absolute
best move recommended by the engine is
just h4 this allows prague to also
create a very strong pass pawn for
example if g captures you're going to
push g3 and once the rook moves uh or
rather maybe even rook to g1 just
pinning the pawn you can play g2 your
pawn is now nicely protected on g2 and
at some point white will have to give up
uh
the exchange for this pawn so while this
is possible uh prague prepares something
else he plays king to f7 and now ling
says all right i i admit i have nothing
better here i could just okay i could
capture on on g4 but then we just trade
on the h file and nothing is really
happening so i'm going to close the uh
the structure play h4 and now it would
seem the game is a draw or maybe i can
do something with my e7 pawn uh far into
the future but still both players are
very low on time so you don't really
have all that much time to plan uh but
now prague will plays rook h the e8 and
after rook to a3 prague goes for uh well
and not for the kill but for
for something to play for more than a
draw he plays rook captures on e7 so he
gives up the rook for bishop and this e7
pawn but not the just for that by doing
this he also
uh will get this rook to see for check
move in
which will all will which will win him
the the c file all to himself as the
bishop covers the c2 square so roku is
not
able to come to c2 it will take ding a
few moves to get back into the game so
here bishop captures an e7 this is an
absolute must rook to c for check now
comes king to b3 and here king captures
on e7 and now there are many ways for
ding to continue this game and there are
many good ways to continue this game
like just a rook to a1 first uh we we we
can prepare this uh but ding plays uh he
he wants to
get rid of black's rook on the c file
even faster and he plays king to b2 he
now wants to play rook to c3 but this uh
simply will not do prague plays king to
d6 now comes rook to c3 here he wants to
trade rooks but now the position is
completely winning for prague so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
uh for prague while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
winning move is the move that is most
often the winning move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show of
course the movie spawned to b4 that's
the good stuff uh now what do you do
with the rook obviously if you just
capture then we play d captures on c4 we
have two connected pass pawns with the
bishop very very strong on this diagonal
this will be just winning and on top of
that we're gonna pick up this pawn then
we're gonna push the a pawn as well
there is nothing for white to do white
has a rook but that rook has absolutely
nothing to do the only way to break
through is if this bishop somehow moves
maybe we can pick up the f pawn but it's
very unlikely that that will happen so
there is no move that ding can play here
king
sorry after b4 rook the c1 was played of
course being did not capture on c4 now
comes king to c6 we are going after this
pawn rook to d2 now
and king to b5 we have rook d to d1
uh and here comes a bishop to f3
challenging the rook on d1
rook to f1 and now just king captures on
a5 so now the a pawn will start marching
forward rook captures on c4 we have d
captures on c4 and now d5 here ding is
hoping for bishop captures and then rook
captures uh this will uh attack the
bishop as the king is on a5
but here prague will just play c3 check
andy was in this position on move 49
that the inglewood resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so really really impressive game against
uh well a very very probable uh
candidate of the 2022 candidates
tournament dingler and here you resign
because well if you go here of course
we want to move the bishop so we can
capture on f5 but if king b3 then we
captured a pawn with check if king c2 we
just play bishop to e4 check and now you
either go up the board and then we
capture with check or you go down the
board then b3 is happening and now look
at this all of the squares are covered
bishop covers this b2 b1 is coming b1 is
covered by the bishop and there is
absolutely nothing white can do here so
of course ding does not play this after
c3 check so a remarkable game by ding
where he shows uh well not just that he
outclassed the ding in preparation as he
played it uh uh well um more precisely
he even made a an improvement on the uh
or rather he didn't make an improvement
ding played sort of a lesser move uh
than in the game that was played in 2015
uh the harikadran naval game that we
mentioned and also
i mean uh okay ding did maybe try to
force it a little bit uh as maybe if h4
was played
in the right moment the game is just a
draw but uh there is no need to draw
right away we will first explore all the
options and then if the game is still a
draw we will draw but prague went for
that beautiful uh we can show it one
more time idea of just
preparing this uh just going after the
pawn giving up the rook for only a
bishop and the pawn
but you can see how much it means to win
the entire uh open file for yourself and
then the two rooks were completely
helpless against the the light square
bishop ended the rook controlling the c
file so a very thematic game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it and uh well just a
brilliant brilliant victory for prague
uh who who came into this game after his
brilliant victory against um
against eric hanson so that was also a
very very clean one
uh so yeah and once again i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
team salo kojo
lucas falcao
radelli uh christy maloney and video
alexa for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching uh and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
incredible event until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out the news and the game
against magnus in the description if you
still haven't seen it see you soon